pour accélérer le retour à l'embauché
des demandeurs d'emploi d'île de france
la région a proposé plusieurs actions
sur le territoire francilien des
secteurs en tension ont besoin
d'employés comme ceux de la santé et de
la sécurité et pour que ces secteurs
deviennent plus attractifs et que les
formations deviennent plus attractives
nous avons décidé de verser une prime
supplémentaire de 1000 euros qui va
s'ajouter aux rémunération habituelle
des stagiaires de la formation
professionnelle
ces formations sont à retrouver sur
l'application oriane forme pro ou sur le
site
oriane point info et pour les jeunes
demandeurs d'emploi beaucoup sont
freinés dans leurs recherches car ils
n'ont pas le permis de conduire
la région va donc leur proposer ynet
nous estimons qu'il ya près de soixante
mille jeunes en insertion en
ile-de-france qui pourraient bénéficier
de cette aide pourra passer leur permis
conduire une aide de 1300 euros qui
correspond au prix moyen d'un permis de
conduire
dix mille places de formation en
e-learning seront également proposés
dans les métiers qui recrutent notamment
dans le domaine du numérique la région
reçoit des crédits du prix qu plan
régional d'investissement dans les
compétences
elle voudrait les mobiliser pour deux
situations différentes qui ne sont pas
encore débloqué qu'on puisse mobiliser
aussi le prix que je lui ai demandé à
elisabeth bornes pour les salariés qui
envisagent une reconversion
professionnelle parce que leur emploi
est menacé on a la possibilité de
maintenir dans des classes théorie des
apprentis qui ne trouvent pas employeur
pour un certain laps de temps et c'est
pas forcément suffisant et donc nous
aimerions pouvoir mobiliser le prix que
pour pouvoir faire des formations
complémentaires de nouveaux campus des
métiers et de qualification seront
également ouverts très prochainement
dans le val de marne et dans le val
d'oise pour renforcer les filières santé
et sécurité